so this is the atsp
hierarchy a system i devised to train
clients across a broad spectrum of
disciplines
and as a guiding principle behind the
notion of super functional training
and my own approach to working out and
enhancing human performance
is something you'll be hearing a lot
more about in a future project that i
can hopefully reveal very soon
so the aim of this system was to design
a method that could be used to train a
person for
anything and to reverse engineer our
diverse range of complex
skills to output specific exercises and
training recommendations
or to help train a client from any
competitive sport or facing any issue
relating to their fitness
at any age so the system applies to
skills both mental and physical
it can also inform a personal training
program towards a specific goal
as part of a larger system that i call
the ability tree
and we'll get to that in a moment as
well so atsp stands for specific
attributes
traits skills and proficiencies in this
context a proficiency is a particular
practice or discipline that you wish to
excel in
so for example martial arts acrobatics
archery
programming surfing running baseball
public speaking singing painting
powerlifting
strongman contortion escapology
such a proficiency is normally comprised
of various
kind of sub skills and techniques for
example the martial artist needs to be
able to perform a number of complex
movements like roundhouse kick
cross etc to dodge and to maintain
exertion for long periods
a programmer on the other hand needs to
think creatively problem solve and focus
they also need to remember a wide range
of different commands and syntax rules
each of these skills and techniques
requires specific traits
a trait could mean cardiovascular
endurance or it could mean rotational
strength
finally specific physical attributes are
the exact physical requirements
necessary for those traits so for
example rotational strength
is dependent on well-developed muscles
that contribute to the therapy effect
the obliques the rhomboids and the
serratus thus in order to become a
better baseball player
like a batter we could consider the
skills and techniques that they use
and then the traits that underlie these
rotational strength hand-eye
coordination grip strength reflexes
calms under pressure traits can be
broader or more specific for example
rotational strength is a trait
but so too is strength or explosive
rotational strength
the more you can narrow down the traits
to what is specifically necessary for
the desired skill though
the more benefit you'll get from the
exercise and then with this information
we can then look at the specific
attributes that underlie
those traits so powerful obliques
rhomboids and serotous anterior
as well as fast visual processing strong
forearm flexors
shoulder mobility and even more obtuse
elements such as low levels of cortisol
and high levels of dhea now we know what
the individual needs to become to
achieve what they hope to achieve
we can prescribe therefore specific
exercises to help them get there faster
we might get the baseball player to
perform pile off presses medicine ball
throws
reaction exercises and vision exercises
important to understand at this point
is that the pyramid with proficiencies
at the top and attributes at the bottom
actually works both ways that is to say
practicing the proficiency itself
and the skills to comprise it will
develop the necessary traits and
attributes
just as the reverse is true so martial
artists can increase hip mobility and
rotational power
if they want to give their kicks more
power and speed
but likewise just practicing the kicks
will naturally improve their hip
mobility
and rotational power training does not
replace practice but should be
supplemental
and aim to enhance strengths and fix
weak points
everything filters up the hierarchy and
it trickles back down
likewise it's important to underscore
the attributes alone will not be
sufficient to develop skills and
proficiencies
there are other inputs besides training
that can enhance an athlete or
individual
at each level this is where the ability
tree comes in
which is not simply for exercising and
training recommendations
but rather includes lifestyle advice and
things like that
the ability tree outlines the following
inputs genetics
practice study training lifestyle and
diet
however it's not limited to just these
for the baseball player considering
these inputs means we can also offer
lifestyle recommendations
and even diet ideas to reduce stress and
increase focus
we might suggest particular books to
offer specific knowledge
we can now observe any impressive
feature ability and break it down to the
constituent parts we need to get there
the same is even true of career options
the ability tree is a broader
application of the atsp hierarchy
designed to provide wider reaching
suggestions for a broader range of
interventions outside of training
so in addition to taking into account
knowledge and the additional inputs
we also place goals at the top of the
pyramid here in other words
why do you want to become adept at a
certain practice do you want to win a
gold medal
become rich move abroad be happier this
then allows us to choose the
proficiencies or abilities that we need
to get to those goals hence ability tree
if your goal is to become a famous
author you first need to write a book
then the practice or ability you need
is writing want to write a lot of words
per day then we need to improve focus
and we might do this by looking at
developing executive control regions of
the brain
such as the anterior cingulate cortex
meditation is known to increase blood
flow to that area
so we might prescribe this as an
effective form of brain training in
service of that goal
using the ability tree to get there we
could also suggest a sufficient amount
of sleep and nutrition etc
we also need to consider the other
inputs at each level of the hierarchy so
learning about writing practicing
writing reading to increase the
vocabulary
the list goes on or if you don't have a
specific goal
what if you want to be super functional
ready for anything
a polymath with a full spectrum of
physical capabilities that we talk about
on this channel
endurance strength speed focus
intelligence mobility
in that case we work backwards we work
from the bottom of the pyramid
up we select the exercises and the tools
that provide the most
different attributes to offer the widest
variety of skills
to make us somewhat proficient even in
practices we've never had the
opportunity to try
this is why i build my workouts around
bang for buck exercises that provide the
widest range of benefits
that develop multiple attributes at once
to deliver the widest range of different
traits and skills in the most efficient
manner
i also like to consider what i call the
super trait and this is a trait that
makes learning every other skill
that much easier and that even helps you
to gain other traits more easily
that includes things like energy which
is a force multiplier because it lets
you do more
and things like plasticity these are
then built from their own
attributes so for instance plasticity at
least requires large amounts of bdnf
and even anabolism but we'll go into
that in more detail
in a future video
[Music]
i hope you found this video useful and
interesting guys and i hope you can find
some use
the atsp hierarchy yourself whether
devising your own training plans
or helping a client is something that's
been really useful for me myself
it's a little peek behind the curtain as
it were all i ask
is that if you use this then please give
me a shout out when you mention the
system
oh and sub and like if you want more
like this and if you want a ready-made
training program based around these
principles that aims to develop every
aspect of human performance
alongside a huge ebook that goes into
depth on all these topics
then be sure to check out my ebook and
training program super functional
training
the link for that one is in the
description down below and there's still
a big discount on right now
whilst we're all still in lockdown man i
thought this discount was going to last
like a month
i certainly misjudged that one hope
you're all safe and healthy guys thank
you so much for watching as always
and i'll see you next time bye for now